>> So I'm here to tell everybody to still
pay attention to Iraq, and to
know that Iraq is instrumental for the stability
and welfare of the
Middle East and the world.
Media attention is often only spotlighted
on Iraq when there's a huge
crisis.
We hope that we reduce the crises and actually
get media attention for
successes in moving forward.
It's going to be a crucial year, 2010 is a
crucial year for Iraq with
new elections on the horizon and many aspirations
for Iraqi people to
get to a better stage in their lives.
It has been a very rough three decades for
the country but we hope in
the coming decades, everyone around the world
will continue to help
Iraq to get back on its feet.
My one wish for 2010 is to have less violence
in Iraq, more hope, and
to give the Iraqi people the opportunities
they truly deserve.